thank you and thank you for nothing
actually no no and now I am pleased to
introduce our next presenter mr. Mike
Meyers who this year refused to do a
movie because he felt the script wasn't
any good what Hollywood is he in there
he is mr. Mike Meyers
now ladies and gentlemen the award we've
all been waiting for Julia okay sound
and sound editing
now I know what you're asking yourself
will the winner this year be Chet flippy
or Tommy blue blue or perhaps even Chad
shivudu girl we don't know but what I do
know is that what's in this envelope is
gonna send shockwaves through the
industry oh yeah
first up Sam the nominees are for
castaway
Randy Tom Tom Johnson Dennis sands and
believe me Kaplan for Gladiators Scott
millon Bob BEMER and Ken Lester
we're the Patriot Kevin O'Connell Greg P
Russell and Lee Orlock for the perfect
storm John writes Greg rude laughs David
Campbell and keep a Western for u-571
Steve Maslow Greg land occur Rick Klein
and Ivan Chirac
and the Oscar goes to
Scott melon Bob BEMER Kim Russell fur
gladiator
the second Oscar and fourth nomination
for Scott Millan and BA femur and the
first Academy Award for Ken Weston he
was nominated in 1996 for Evita
well first of all we'd like to dedicate
this award to Ken Weston the other
member of our crew who couldn't be here
tonight he's at home and we miss him
we'd also like to thank Ridley Scott for
his vision and his generosity we'd like
to thank DreamWorks Universal Pictures
of course Walter parks and Laurie
McDonald Marty Cohen and Lisa Dennis
Kennedy we're proud to congratulate Doug
wick David Franz Oni and Branko Lustig
for a truly great film as well as our
picture editor Pietro Scalia and
composers Hans Zimmer and Lisa Gerrard
and everyone at Tadeo studios and a very
special thanks to our supervising sound
editor Perry Hall Berg and his great
crew and to our family Cindy Jessica and
Amy and mom and dad and Deborah Ashley
and Brandon and thank you the Academy
thank you
the nominees for sound editing are for
space cowboys Allen Robert Murray and
Bob Asman for u-571 John Johnson and the
Oscar goes to John Johnson for u-571
the first Academy Award and nomination
for John Johnson
oh wait clocks tickin got this going all
right first off my thanks the producers
of u-571 Dino and Martha DiLaurentis who
make it exciting and an honor to be in
this business
the director Jonathan Mostow thank for
your loyalty talent and tenacity to my
whole crew my deepest thanks I'd like to
mention a few of them that have tortured
the longest Miguel Rivera Keith
bilderbeck Val kook Lasky's Bruce
Stubblefield Robert Roy to the mixers
brick Steve Gregg and I haven't you guys
set the bar for the best mix I've ever
been through - my partner chief
antagonist fiercest promoter most loyal
friend and my wife Jill I love you
forever and after kids don't stay up
tonight we'll be out real late